Bot: My mortal flesh is no longer limiting by this pathetic Youtuber.
Phase 1 is almost,
complete.
Pewds: Hey how's it going Bros!
My name is PewDiePie!
So today, I'm very excited because I get to announce something that we've been working on for quite a while,
and I'm very very proud of it.
It's really cool
You already know what it is,
so I dont know why I'm try- (d jsound)
trying to say it like it's secret
"PewDieBot"
I finally
have
my own PewDieBot.
I will literally live forever now,
through this thing.
Ya'll haters, wish I was gone,
but I bet if I actually disappeared you would miss me, you actually love me.
Well now you can.
When I'm gone, this bot will still be here
when I'm gone, this bot will take over the universe
when I'm gone, this bot will fist you daddy.
*baby crying*
I had to record so much material,
I thought I was going insane.
Still sounds like I had sex with a robot and this is what came out.
I don't know if you're into that kinda stuff or not, but the PewDieBot is here.
It is so much fun to play with,
we put everything that relates to me in it,
and you will see that when you talk to PewDieBot.
The game is available right now on Android and iOS.
It's real. (laughs) I really recommend that you check it out.
Link is in the description,
and that would really support all the work that we put into this,
because it does cost to make and it does cost to run the servers and all that kinda stuff so...
if you're interested in this and wanna check it out, link is in the description.
I'm really happy with it and I can't wait to see you bros, what kinda conversations you will have with me.
So we put a buncha easter eggs in the game, here's what it looks like if you find one.
"Wow, honestly great job, can't believe you found this easter egg."
"egg 001".
So the first one that tweet me hashtag "pewdiebot" and hashtag "the easter egg",
will get a retweet.
I'm really curious if you bros are gonna find all the easter eggs and how long it will take.
Oh my God, it scares me so much...
Just looking at myself like that is terrifying.
You have great hair though, it looks very nice.
Hey, don't smile back at that!
Another cool thing with this is that eventually you'll be able to speak your own language.
You'll be able to talk to me in your own native tongue.
Oh my God, what is happening?
Ok... How is it going, bro?
I am the biggest bro on the planet
You are! You are the biggest bro on the planet!
Aww man... Notice me senpai!
heh heh heh heh!
Notice me senpai!
Please notice me senpai!
"Never"
C'mon, this is getting a little awkward.
N-Notice me senpai!
"Fine, I've noticed how you are still here"
Aww man.
Hey pewdiepie! Fist me daddy.
"Please see therapy"
Uuhhh, I know the voice is a lil wonky. We will update it so it does sound better.
I don't wanna do too much with it, I will make a video where I really fuck with it.
I wanna see you bros fuck with it first.
I wanna see you bros fuck with me.
I wanna see you bros fuck me lit--- (no)
I cant wait to see what kinda conversations you have.
I also just want to say a quick thanks to Existor for working on this bot,
they really put a lot of time and effort into making it,
check out the link in the description.
Thank you so much to everyone supporting this,
I really really appreciate it.
So excited that you bros can finally play with me.
Literally.
That's it for now! I'll see you bros,
And as always,
Stay awesome Bros!